I was really really young and I remember
not being a feeling like I couldn't
breathe and reading to my mom and being
like mom I feel like I can't breathe
something must be wrong
kendall Jenner is opening up about her
struggle with anxiety she of course took
me to a bunch of doctors just to make
sure it was all okay physically and I
was no one ever told me that I had
anxiety the model has teamed up with
Kenneth Cole to help launch the mental
health coalition which was created to
change the culture surrounding mental
health and on Friday the 24 year olds
got candid during a chat with Michael
Strahan on Good Morning America about
her own experiences with anxiety
starting from a young age maybe like
three four years ago it came back
completely full-on and I would have
crazy panic attacks finally kind of got
the information that I needed about it
by speaking about your anxiety and
sharing your video what do you hope to
accomplish honestly what I hope to
accomplish is for people to not feel as
alone and it's something we've seen on
Keeping Up with the Kardashians
Kendall's struggles from anxiety and I
think she has so much going on that she
gets herself really work job I try and
maintain it but sometimes it's like out
of your control anxieties all mental so
you have to try and find your ways
around it then the Keeping Up Star
explained what she's been doing to take
care of her mental health in the days
but I don't really have as much going on
I I tend to get a bit anxious and I to
calm myself down I'll usually read a
book or meditate
Kendall also hit up her social media to
spread awareness hey guys just checking
in I have been doing a lot of thinking
during quarantine mostly about mental
health and how important it is always
but especially in these times with the
devastation of coronavirus and I just
wanted to instill some hope in people
and know that everyone's not alone in
this isolation so I have decided to join
a challenge called how are you really
challenged which basically lets people
know how you're really feeling and she
nominated her sister Kim Kardashian
Justin and Hailey Bieber and Jen Atkin
to join the challenge sharing how
they're feeling - for me I have good
days and I have some really anxious days
so I'm kind of off and on but I want you
to join me in this challenge I want you
to tell me how you really feel and know
that you're not alone and know that
we're going to get through this together
[Music]